hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and I forgot to unmute my
[Music]
mic noticing it in 3 2 1 well that was
muted hello everybody my name is markip
and welcome to my eyes
deceive I started recording and then I
didn't notice the letters undulating
before my eyes and my microphone was
muted but now you can hear
me anyway there's a story here so you
may think that this is a Roblox
game and you would sort of be right this
game is not the Roblox version because
this game is the original and the Roblox
was a recreation of this one there's
actually a little interesting story here
why was my eyes to see you taken off of
Roblox in response to my request the
Roblox version of my eyes deceived has
been removed from the platform some of
you may wonder why so I'd like to
provide an explanation I dedicated
months to creating this project
releasing it in May of 23 however it
received barely in attention from both
the general audience on itch and from
YouTubers sometimes later I met the one
of the developers of cheese blocks
whatever that is informed me in the
comments who asked if they could
recreate it in Roblox without giving him
much thought at the time I gave
permission fast forward to October I had
a pretty rough week Roblox Recreation of
my sees gained immense popularity with
several big content creators posting
videos about it initially I was happy
about the intention however in the last
couple days an increasing number of
videos were being released by even
bigger content creators and the issue
was that almost none of them credit the
original game in the description or
mentioned it in the video it felt until
the recreation of my work was being
overshadowed and not given the
recognition I felt it deserved after a
week of contemplation I made the
decision to request the owners of cheese
blocks to take it down I understand that
this might appear selfish to some but
it's the decision I've come to and I
believe it's for the best once again I'd
like to express my gratitude for their
cooperation and I wish them the best of
luck at their future projects so I'm
here to play the
OG the original the undiluted of my eyes
deceive which apparently a lot of people
were saying was like pretty cool so I'm
going to do this because I missed it
before because if the timeline lines up
I was filming iron lung at the time and
I wasn't able to do a whole bunch of
stuff all right I'm ready to have my
eyes deceived people say it's really
good and I'm sure there's a reason why
it got popular on Roblox because if it's
a remake of a good game it'll be good
probably and also I like seriously this
person made it so if there is anyone
upset that the Roblox version is gone
just remember it's it's a game you can
it's just you get it somewhere else and
the original Creator wanted it just on
theirs because it is kind of unfair that
the Remake would get way more attention
or the OG would get no attention at all
take your pills all
right
pills
yum
[Music]
yum drink some water you'd think I would
have thought of that
beforehand why is the walls made of
[Music]
cork why am I so blow to the
[Laughter]
ground prepare some
food
okay that is my food for today just one
bite and I'm all
good
[Music]
okay great wash
myself here now in front of everybody
watching
ooh I still have stuff to do
uh-huh you look
thirsty all right I shall wash
myself
wait for
father
okay lady I'm waiting for
father oh freerunner oh kid Pat that
explains why I'm so
Stumpy
uh-huh
okay ah I see I just got to keep
away okay
[Music]
okay oh
god yoink oh I'm so goddamn good damn
I'm good wish I could control it with my
mouse though all
right well that was fun
father talk with papa
papa where is you you
papa
[Music]
PE okay
father I don't know if I need to water
these things but I will now that I don't
have anything wrong with Roblox
necessarily keep going little one but
someday I know there are quite a few
horror games on there some original
horror games so not all of them are just
copies of things but there are horror
games on Roblox and I've been meaning to
get around to them so if there are any
good ones I would like to know about it
hopefully ones that are not just copies
now this one had that one had permission
I'm not saying this game on Roblox
didn't have permission that's what I'm
saying where is
papaa
happy I'm
confused pop
oh Hello
darling are you
here yes
papa will you come down
today no
honey you should really know
better you could get
infected did you take your
pills
yes they're making me feel sleepy
again then you should probably go to bed
can't you tell me a story from
outside
[Music]
please okay but I will keep it
short today I saw a very scary creature
this is not a good Story upon seeing it
I felt immense
Terror however I managed to
escape that's why you mustn't try to
leave I'd hate for them to find
you thank you for protecting
me I'm very
tired I think I'll go to bed
oh before you
go I have something for
you a
diary so you don't get
bored thank
you no worries my
dear okay
now sleep well
bye-bye okay well this is going to be
really depressing I can feel that this
game is going to be less about horrific
horrific which I bet it'll have and more
about being just just incredibly
depressing I could already tell right in
my diary
where where oh dear
[Music]
diary today papa gave me this diary I'm
so happy he also told me a story from
the outside seems like a very scary
place you'll hear from me tomorrow
okay all right this is going to
be probably G to
be probably G to be
sad good morning
oh that's
fine oh that's
fine
oh well
hi well
that's that's
fun
okay
no so when do I get my stapler where are
the
squirrels all right take my P
bills
good drink some
[Music]
water how did the food get down here
that's what I want to know how'd the
food get here prepare some
food
uhhuh everything a growing child
needs wash myself
[Music]
okay
yippee wait for Papa
okay just enough time to water the
plants grow big and strong all right
Papa hey hey hey
PE
father father ah oh I
see oh boy there goes my light in case
you didn't know it's a little haunted
but just a little bit not a
lot oh
pop hey
pop father
help I'm
back how are you
feeling I feel very
good I slept
amazingly even though I had a weird
dream are you okay mhm I'm fine don't
worry did you take your pills today yes
I really have to take them every day oh
of course it's for your own good they
prevent
scurvy and infection it's important that
you take them every day all right all
right shut up about it did you find
something cool uh yes I managed to
gather some
food and other supplies did you run into
a monster again big scary one
unfortunately yes the world outside is a
mess horrible place you wouldn't like it
monsters are imitating human voices if
you hear anyone besides
me do not make a sound they mustn't find
you I'm scared Papa what if they make
your voice how do I know it's really you
oh boy I don't like where this is going
let's think of a
password what about
Apple what's that a sparse resource a
delicious type of food if I manag to
find
one I'll give it to you I'm [__] I'm
excited aren't you tired yet now that
you mention it no oh I should go to
bed
Henry I swear if Henry doesn't stop
barking I'm going to bring him in here
and I'm going to put him on camera he
does not like that but I'm going to do
it if he doesn't stop
barking he's got he's done it now
Henry Henry's here
Henry why are you
barking why do you keep barking H why do
you keep barking why are you barking
little boy little boy
quack tell the world why are you
barking no all right get out of here
stop barking who bets he's going to
bark
no
barks
interesting well I guess he learned his
lesson all I'm going write in my diary
now what did I miss did anything spooky
happen while I was away dear diary I
better remember the word
Apple oh the world outside is a mess
what does he
mean
huh oh
I guess this one is this a roar Shack
test is this is this going to turn into
my
fears is this going to turn into that
which scares me today Papa has told me
about something called apple he said it
is very rare because the world outside
is a mess I'm scared of the outside
there are many
monsters I bet there
are and I bet that my nightmare tonight
is going to be uh very much
like okay it's just
dark
okay oh
boy oh
oh
ah I
see what's seems like the Shadows are
emanating from this direction so I'll
trace it back to the source unless
they're just going in both both
directions or no
directions or none at all I'll go this
way I always had a good feeling but
they're coming from
there or they're going both ways this is
trippy okay
I do think this is based on the image
that I
picked my perception of reality is very
limited and I don't have any good
understanding what actually is above the
surface I don't even know if pop pop is
lying to
me about the
monsters but it's probably for the best
that I remember the word Apple how are
they doing this this is kind of cool
well my eyes are certainly deceiving me
because I don't know what the hell I'm
doing I think I'm going the right way
but I don't even know what my objective
is so I wouldn't know objectively what
the right way is oh there's a thing an
apple could it be an
apple wow that's not an apple is that
an bendy I should take my
pills seriously that looks like bendy
you know and the ink machine hey wait I
don't have any food no food I should
check the
cupboard do I have a
cupboard there's some old food
[Music]
left wash myself la la I should probably
also take note the things that I'm doing
that are making noise which is pretty
much everything so I shouldn't do
anything hopefully father brings some
food I'm a little bit famished all right
L LA one rock for me got a rash in it
and maybe a little level oh well hi
guys wow was that a Henry bark guys I
think he bfed you know what that means
got to take his legs just like chica he
lost his leg
privileges
y making fools of these guys I mean they
get so clumped up they basically sto
themselves where's
papa
[Music]
papa pop
pop
where's
father oh oh where's papa where is
[Music]
Father father you here
where are
[Music]
you hry okay that's fine I am going to
say some comforting words that's going
to keep all of us encouraged and look
looking forward to the next day where
things will
surely be better and now a performance
by marip plier he didn't come home
today uh where is Papa where is Papa
where is Papa where is Papa where is
Papa where is
Papa where is is Papa where is Papa
today Papa didn't come home I was all
alone and scared I hope he comes back
tomorrow I hate it when I'm
alone yeah I get
you
[Music]
I wouldn't know what to
right
[Music]
uh-huh
okay oh boy CH good just just dreams
nice oh
yeah oh whoa why did you look at that I
don't know if I was supposed to to see
that
happen
okay great this is
awesome really starting to lose it you
know uh-huh just going to ignore the
ghostly Apparition at the end of the
hallways that's probably
fine did I just go back back to the
beginning or no I did
not oh
boy oh
boy oh good I'm in the back rooms of my
mind
this vaguely reminds me of that I'm sure
a few other people might have already
started to pick up
on is Vibes of presentable
Liberty it's been a long time since I
played that game and it's been a long
time since I've played another game that
has kind of captured similar Vibes to it
this one definitely do that I don't know
if I was supposed to do that wait a
minute six uh-huh this is good good
stuff good stuff just a kind of looping
monotony I don't have any food still no
food oh well that's nice that's that's
good that's good I mean I have running
water that's got to be telling of
something of the
outside and wait for
father all right let me just water the
plans we have our little rituals that we
do every morning we
just lovingly do them our routines that
keep us grounded as make us feel the
same or at least somewhat sane it was
that kind of like l loneliness that
presentable Liberty captured but not
even just a
loneliness but it was like a yearning
right it created a sense of Yearning not
just for freedom but to know more to see
like beyond your surroundings which I
guess is in a way a sense of Yearning
For Freedom that was in the name of the
game is whoa is like presentable Liberty
you know I don't know if that name has
meaning but in a way it's kind of just
you know this hopelessness that it
conjures and the relationship you build
with people that you can't even see
which is somewhat descriptive of the
internet as a whole and definitely
social status as they occur in these
situations I doubt that the developer of
presentable Liberty could have ever uh
imagined what say like Co would have
been like with all the lockdowns and the
kind of Separation but also with the
Resurgence of you know people working
from home and studying from home being
home but also the ramifications of you
know the co lockdown have yet to even
been fully manifested you know what
having just even one year let alone
however many it was slightly more than a
year actually of just like break from
the rhythm of what normal life would be
kind of I don't know it just gives you a
sense even this with its game I believe
that present of Liberty had like this
kind of game
and just occupying yourself with you
know things not saying that life before
the internet didn't have moments of
boredom I wouldn't know I uh I've kind
of had the internet all my life even
though the the first iterations of it
were extremely rudimentary for
me yeah even me like had the internet
maybe not as a i no I mean pretty
soon just downloading
old Doom Maps or my dad was anyway
I don't know just a fascinating little
idea I try to imagine what it's like
before there
were you know computers and I can't cuz
like computers were in my life since the
very beginning I can't imagine what it
would have been like to try to entertain
yourself as a kid especially um when you
didn't have anyone to play with I'm
whoa oh
God where's
papa
I don't
know
[Music]
Papa not today
either I'm not doing good guys I mean
I'm I'm fine but I the eye that I put
into these games in these videos
the little piece of
myself not doing
okay is Papa not coming home do I need
to take my pills I'm going to say I do
look let's just say this isn't a
post-apocalyptic nightmare there's
probably still a good reason for me to
take a daily medication
um probably one thing I've learned about
these types of games is that choice is
an illusion and it's more symbolic than
anything and so you can fret over these
decisions all you want the way I see it
is in this aspect your perspective
applies the choice your perspective
applies meaning to the choice itself and
the choice doesn't have to give you
meaning you've already had the meaning
applied to it and for me the meaning is
I hold on to hope that my dad's going to
come back and that he wanted me to take
the pill and I have hope that this isn't
a horrible situation well I mean it's
probably horrible situation no matter
what but I'm going keep keep choosing to
take the pills because I apply the
meaning that that means that I'm still
holding on to hope and I'm not going to
give up and no matter what it's going to
make me feel bad about the choice anyway
so I'm going to take him he's still not
coming it's been 4 days now the pills
make me tired if he's not coming do I
even have to take them I think I should
they're protecting me meaning and I know
that I don't have to check this area in
between each bout of pill induced
sleepiness and it's probably all going
to be terrible no matter what I do but I
get to dictate the meaning in my mind
and no one can take that away from
me CU without the parameters you can
Wonder all you want about what this
means what it is without the context
there in you can only take Sals in the
decisions that you make and the meaning
that you apply and when the truth when
the truth is Reve Feld then you change
your perspectives to apply new meaning
and I don't like the meaning that's
about to be applied
here but to destroy yourself over
meaning that you never could have
obtained
that that lead you oh
boy leads you down a dark slope that
chair was not turned like that
before my game I was so close to being
done uhhuh well we're going to get PT
scared that's for damn sure oh
boy is this
symbolism oh
boy feel like it might be some
Bo oh
boy oh boy oh
boy oh
boy
oh
boy oh it's my
pills
I
okay man funny dream
drink some water Okie
doie oh is that
[Laughter]
food there's food is he
back oh
[Applause]
boy is that like a trapo or something
that drops the food down how does the
food get here and that's what I was
talking about is like technically
speaking you know when it comes to
decisions like this or you know even in
life I guess you could apply to greater
things remember this is just a game it's
just a story no matter how horrible it
could possibly
become which is probably fine I don't
know but what it comes down to when you
have decision with no information you
just got to like I don't know for me you
just got to trust in yourself and the
people that you trust until that trust
is broken and then you can make a
decision from there I suppose but you
know you can't beat yourself up over
things you didn't know anyway I'm going
to finish that game that's what I know
I'm going to do and that's what I'm
going to beat freerunner oh my
god wow look at me go you can never beat
this
yippe
oh perfect
timing
Papa that was ominously timed light
going out there that all right pop
up hey
sweetie you're
back yes princess I'm
back wait what's the
password
Apple it's actually
you where did you go I'm sorry something
urgent came up I had to leave for a
couple days it won't happen
again
promise promise how have you been have
you been taking your bills I've been
fine I had to eat some leftovers though
but that wasn't a problem at all it's a
little crusty a little
little uh chalky I also took the pills
every day because I trust you papa I'm
glad to
hear also as an
[Music]
apology okay brought you something what
is it that is an
apple so that's what it looks like try
eating it
soon they're best when they're fresh I'm
G look down it's a beating heart I'm
like an apple I'll try it before going
to sleep are feeling
tired yeah a bit that's good head to bed
then honey sweet
dreams see you
tomorrow try the Apple okay
sure where is it I don't know why I
thought the Apple would be in the shower
but all right
Apple wow it's so sweet and
juicy oh hell yeah hell
yeah today Papa came back I'm very happy
and he also gave me an Apple I didn't
think it would be so tasty I hope he can
bring me some more
soon well that's a happy ending If Ever
I heard one what a wonderful experience
I'm sure it's going to end
now
oh
what
oh got a
trophy I got a
trophy
oh
what
huh
[Music]
h
huh huh this really does feel like
presentable
Liberty towards the end you get so used
to a
routine things suddenly feel very
different and I don't know why imagine
if I had to go through all 147 days why
are my plants not Papa hold on Papa I
got to water the
plants I've been watering them every day
Papa I would have thought that there
would have been some change if this was
the last day I have been watering them
every day even the first one I think I
don't think I went to bed without
watering
them I don't think I would have
forgotten again it's that thing where
you start to question it if the habits
but I trust that the habits that I was
forming I had definitely did and I guess
I can't really follow myself if I missed
one
Papa
[Music]
what see that's the
thing makes you feel bad about the
decisions you make makes you feel bad
about it I knew that it was going to be
some [__] up twist at the end I knew
it I knew it you know what I knew it I'm
not even going to explain it for those
who don't understand I'm not even going
to explain it so in
this it was a situation well at least
that's what that's implying situation
where everything's all everything [__]
but the question is the question that I
have for myself is and this is exactly
what I was saying you do the decisions
that you have based on the information
that you're presented with and you have
to
like understand that your your natural
inclinations are biased towards it and
then retroactively applying information
can be devastating you know to the
psyche but at the same time I mean let
let's be I've seen Cloverfield Lane I've
SE I this it you know how dare you newad
Dev how could you how could you do this
it does make me want to know what occurs
when you don't do that but I think this
is a perfectly good opportunity for you
guys to discover something about this
game because apparently like I said at
the beginning of this video there was a
Roblox version of this and it got way
way way more attention than this version
which is the original version it's not
even a version of it this is the game
and that is the developer and there is
another ending and another path to take
what is the truth will it make you feel
just as bad if you go that direction
what if it was an apocalypse it was a
game I was playing I don't know could
have been zombies and monsters out there
I got an apple but you guys can discover
the truth about this maybe I'm applying
too much meaning towards that ending
even though it seems pretty obvious that
everything's kind of messed up link is
in the description support the developer
make a choice I'm sure I won't make you
feel bad about it afterwards
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next
video
bye-bye